Guten Tag, Özdemünist, mein Name ist Daniela Hoffmann.
Ich, Daniela Frau Hoffmann, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vorn und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Mein Nachname ist Hoffmann H-O-F-M-A-N-N. Mein Vorname ist D-A-N-I-E-L-A, Daniela.
Ich bin Hoffmann, mit Zwischen F, Friedrich und Anton M.
Ich bin Doppel-M-A-N-N.
Ich bin Hoffmann.
Ich verstehe, wie alt sind Sie, Frau Hoffmann?
Ich bin 55 Jahre alt.
Verraten Sie bitte Ihr Gewusstatum?
Ich bin 25. Januar 1971.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 1,65 m groß und ich gehe 72 kg.
Sind ein paar Elagien oder Verträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein.
Frau Hoffmann, was hat sie zu uns geführt?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit über 6 Monaten Schmerzen in den Fingern habe.
Fingerrahmen?
Finger, in den Fingern.
Ja, Finger, verstehe.
Beide Hände sind die Grundgelenke und die Mittelgelenke.
Und dabei, ja, verspüren Sie Schmerzen und ja, eine Rötung, Schwelung auch dabei?
Ja, die sind beide ein bisschen geschwollen, aber heute sind sie nicht.
Und australen Schmerzen, irgendwo in andere Körperregionen aus?
Nein, das bleibt in den Fingern und auch in den Händen.
Okay, wir sind diese Schmerzen aufgetreten, wissen Sie?
Nein, nein.
Schleichend, meine Sie.
Erinnern Sie sich an einen Auslöse dafür?
Nein.
Nein, wissen Sie nicht.
Alle, Ihre Finger und auch Ihre Gelenke, auch eine große Gelenke mit vieler Handgelenke?
Handgelenke nicht, sondern eher die Fingergelenke, Handgelenke weniger, aber auch.
Jetzt sind eher die Fingergelenke.
Und ja, leiden Sie unter eine Steifigkeit am Morgenst?
Noch mal?
Ja, leiden Sie unter eine Steifigkeit morgens, vielleicht eine Langdämpfe?
Ja, die Finger sind etwas angespannt und ich kann die nicht so gut bewegen morgens.
Deswegen waren die in anderer Art?
Ich war schon beim Hausarzt gewesen, wir hatten mir Medikamente aufgeschrieben, das hat aber nicht viel gebracht.
Welches Medikament?
Im Problem.
Wie viel Milligramm, wie stark ist die Dosierung?
400 Milligramm.
Wie lange haben Sie angenommen und zurzeit nicht mehr?
Ich stelle die weiterhin ein, ich stelle die jetzt schon seit über 2 Wochen ein.
3 Mal an Tag.
Ja, hat diese Medikamente Ihnen geholfen, ein bisschen gelindert?
Ganz wenig, nicht viel, ganz wenig.
Haben Sie noch etwas unternommen, vielleicht eine Wärmeanwendung oder kalte Anwendung?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nicht.
Ja, möchte ich etwas über diese Schmassen wissen?
Wie stark sind die Schmassen auf einer Schmastikal, wobei ein kaum Schmassen aussehen und erträglichen Schmassen entspricht?
Ja, 5 würde ich sagen.
Immer 5 oder gibt es etwas, das diese Schmassen zu lindern oder verstärkt?
Ich habe immer 5, manchmal 4, nach Ibuprofen, aber meistens 5.
Welche Charakter haben diese Schmassen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ja, ich meine eher Dumpfstichen oder Drücken.
Ja, es sind so dumpfe manchmal stetsende Schmerzen.
Okay, und hätten Sie einen Unfall?
Vielleicht.
Aber alle Ihre Gerenke haben betroffen, ja?
Genau.
Ich habe immer ein bisschen Fieber, ich bin ein bisschen müde.
Das ist jetzt nicht hohes Fieber, aber so Subfibrillen, 36, 8, 37 um den Dreh.
Okay, und?
Ich bin auch sehr abgeschlagen, muss man sein.
Haben Sie auch in letzter Zeit eine Hauteränderung bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Eine große Pumptiartepflege vielleicht?
Wie ist die Appetit?
In letzter Zeit hat sie verändert?
Eigentlich gut.
Haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten verändert?
Ich habe etwas abgenommen, ich habe 2 bis 3 Giga abgenommen.
Das war ungewollt, oder?
Haben Sie eine Diät gemacht?
Nein, ich habe keine Diät gemacht.
Schlafen Sie gut, Herr Häusam, Frau Hofmann?
Eigentlich schlafe ich gut, aber wenn ich Schmerzen habe,
ist ich ein bisschen unruhig, meine Regel ist,
dass man schlafen kann, nicht beeindruckend.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten oder Probleme beim Wasserlassen
oder mit der Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Noch einige Fragen zu stellen, möchte ich zurück.
An Amnesi gehen, haben Sie auch eine kribbelnde Taupasse
geführt, Ihre Hände oder eine Verstellung bei der Hände?
Nein, ich kann nur keine Faust machen, das ist schwierig.
Können Sie nicht bewegen, genau, oder?
Ja, es ist schwierig, es tut weh.
Ich würde gerne mal über Ihre Krankenvorgeschichte beginnen
und leiden Sie an irgendeine kronische Erkrankung?
Ja, warum?
Anzug an Krankheit oder Bluthochdruck oder Krebs?
Nein, ich habe keinen Krebs, ich habe eine drüßende Unterfunktion.
Seit wann haben Sie solche?
Ich habe seit 20 Jahren.
Nach einer Operation, haben Sie vielleicht Schilddrüsen
unter Funktion oder...
Es wurde damals festgestellt, wo ich ungefähr 33 Jahre alt war,
und da hat man mir eine Medikamentverordnung,
man hat mal abgesagt, dass die Schilddrüse zu groß sein.
Oh, verstehe.
Groß und hat man auch Knoten oder Nudeln?
Das wurde nicht gesagt.
Und noch weitere Erkrankungen bei Ihnen bekannt?
Das verdient nicht, nicht das Schluß zum Rücken.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Regie-Hemission
oder bedarfweise Medikamente ein?
Ja, Ibuprofen habe ich schon gesagt, wegen Schmerzen.
Ich nehme auch für die Schilddrüse
eine Schilddrüse, die ich auch schon gesehen habe.
Wie viel Milligramm?
50 Mikrogramm.
Einmal oder?
Einmal morgens.
Sind Sie schon mal aufreiert worden?
Ich will nicht, ich habe noch nie.
Oh Gott sei Dank.
Ja, Frau Hofmann, darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ich rauche ja.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Ungefähr 10 Stück am Tag.
Seit wann rauchen Sie mit dieser Dosierung?
Ich habe früher mehr geraucht,
ich habe früher auch eine ganze Packung geraucht,
aber ich rauche jetzt seit 5 Jahren ungefähr 10 Stück.
Und früher, viel Jahr haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, ich habe früher mehr geraucht,
ich habe früher mehr ganze Packung geraucht,
also ungefähr 20 Stück.
Ja, 20 Stück, aber wie viele Jahre?
Ja, genau.
Das ist schon auch jetzt ungefähr über 30 Jahre,
ich habe 20 Jahre angefangen, 19, 20 Jahre,
also ungefähr über 30 Jahre schon jetzt.
Okay, verstehe.
Frau Hofmann, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten.
Was trinken Sie?
Also ich trinke sehr gerne Cocktails.
Cocktails.
Und nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, weil wir es vornehmen.
Das ist eine reine Routine Frage,
ja bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, ja natürlich.
Und steht hier in meiner Frage bogen, ja okay, aber keine.
Ich vermute, dass Sie, das hat sie nicht zu tun.
Und ja, Frau Hofmann,
ich gehe so Ihre Familien vorgeschrieben
und gebe es in Ihrer Nähenverwandtschaft
eine wichtige Erkrankung oder
kurne schärfliche Erkrankung, Krebsfälle auch.
Also mein Vater hatte tatsächlich Bauchschweiche durch den Krebs.
Meine Mutter, die lebt noch, mein Vater ist verstorben.
Meine Mutter lebt noch, die hat auch Blutdruck,
Zuckererkrankungen, die hat auch Rheumerkrankungen,
die hat auch viel.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
Eine Rheume ist bekannt auch.
Und haben Sie die Schwester?
Ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Einzel, okay, gut.
Was machen Sie, Frau Hofmann?
Ich bin Bürokaufrau.
Können Sie Ihre Tätigkeit erledigen bei dieser Position?
Ja, das ist schwierig, weil ich kann sehr schlecht auf Ihnen
Pastatur vom Computer zippen.
Es wird immer schwieriger, auch die Maus zu bedienen.
Es wird schwierig.
Ich bin sehr angestellt.
Ich verstehe natürlich.
Ich kann Ihnen sehr gut noch vorstellen.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin geschieden.
Ich bin ein Profter, und bin geschieden.
Ist Ihre Torte gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Gibt es in Ihrer Alltag oder bei der Arbeit etwas, was Sie belastet?
Fühlen Sie sich unter Stress?
Ja, mir hat immer Stress auf die Arbeit.
Sie sind vollständig geübt?
Ich denke schon, mein Haushalt hat nichts gesagt.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit verreist in Asien?
Nein.
Ja, und Frau Hofmann?
Ich möchte noch gerne wissen,
ob Sie eine Wanderung gemacht haben?
Nicht, dass ich das wüsste.
Das war meine Frage.
Ich will noch einige Fragen über Ihre genokologische Sache.
Sie haben eine Regeln-Messig-Bulutung?
Sie können es sein, dass Sie zuvor schwanger sind?
Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Nehmen Sie Pille oder eine Verwaltung?
Frau Hofmann, jetzt sind wir durch über unsere Fragen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Zeit Ergänzungen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Ich würde nur gerne wissen, was ich habe und ob Sie mir helfen können.
Frau Hofmann, ich kann noch nicht genau sagen, was Ihnen fehlt.
Aber bisherige Angaben oder Informationen könnte es sich um eine Gelenkentschuldung handeln
und ich erkläre Ihnen, was wir weitergehen.
Ich werde kurz Sie als erstes Köpferchen untersuchen, dann Bluntentnahme durchführen.
Dann würde ich eine technische Untersuchung bei Ihnen durchführen.
Sobald eine Ergebnis hier vorliegt, könnte ich Ihnen schrittweise erklären,
welche Diagnose Sie haben und welche Verwaltung Sie haben.
Schönen Sie uns noch eine andere Frage?
Ich habe nicht gehört, wie groß und wie schwer Sie sind.
Ich bin 25 kg.
Danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Das war jetzt für drei Monate gewesen.
Danke.
Haben Sie die Zone empfindlich gemacht?
Nein.
Das ist eine Diagnose, die wir auf der Diagnose haben.
Wir haben eine Diagnose, die wir auf der Diagnose haben.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Guten Tag.
Herr Oberstein, Herr R, habe ich eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich vorstellen würde, hätten Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Natürlich.
Vielen Dank.
Es geht um Frau Daniela Hofmann, 55 Jahre alt.
Jahre alt geboren am 25. Januar 1971. Sie wiegt so seit 72 Kilogramm und sie ist 1 Meter 65
vor. Die Patientin wurde in unserer Klinik wegen ungefähr 6 Monaten beste Hände schon
nicht mehr in beide Hände, beide Finger im Grund- und Mittelgelenk vorstellen. Laut
angabende Patienten sei die Gelänke überwärmt und erricht bei der Gelänke
geschwollt und gerötet gewesen. Bei Belastung verstärken sich die Schmerzen. In der hausarztliche
Vorstellung wurde bei ihr eine Überproofung von 500 Milligramm verschrieben und die Einnahme
von Überprüfen hat Gelänke vorbegehend die Linde gebracht. Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 von 10 auf
einer Schmerzskala nach einer Überprüfen-Name liegt bei 5 von 10. Die Patientin beschrieb die Schmerzen
als dumpf und stehend und begleitend habe sie eine Astenie und Möglichkeit. In der vegetativen
Anamnese sind folgendes ergeben. Pyrrexie bis 37,8 und Gewichtabnahme von 2 bis 3 Kilogramm in
den letzten 6 Monaten und eine Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörung. Bekannt ist eine
Hypertrose seit 20 Jahren. Dagegen nehmen sie ein L-Trog 50 Mikrogramm einmal morgens und sie
sind 5 Jahre alt und früher einen Konsum von 25 Pakungsjahren. Ansonsten in der Familienanamnese
fanden sich ein Pancreas-Kastion bei dem Vater und eine arterielle Hypertonie und die
Bitesmetos und Rheumatide artritis bei der Mutter. Es arbeitet als Brückerfrau geschieden und Mutter von
einem Tochter. Im Status ist vollständig und Reiseanamnese ist negativ und die geniökologische
Anamnese ist unauffällig. Und die anamnistischen Angaben, aufgrund der anamnistischen Angaben ergibt
sich hier ein Verdacht auf Rheumatide artritis und da die Patienten eine 6 Monate bestehende
Schwellung und Schwellungrötung bei Finder und Grund- und Mittelgelenks dabei eine
Inappetenz und Fieber besteht. Ansonsten ein Name von Überprüfen habe bei diesem Zustand keine
Linderung gebracht und deswegen sprechen diese Informationen für eine, in meiner Meinung nach,
eine Artriotes. Warum kann es keine Arthrose sein? Ja, Arthrose, warum nicht sein? Ja, bei
dieser Alter kann man auch eine Arthrose denken, aber hier eine geschwollene und gerötete
Gelenke und das ist ein Entzündungszeitnern von einer Gelenke und auch eine Überprüfen-Einnahme.
Keine Linderung, ja, keine, ja, nicht geholfen hat. Deswegen habe ich einen Verdacht auf Rheuma gedacht.
Und auch die, es ist nicht auch eine große Gelenk, sondern ja, eine Kleingelenk in Finger.
Keine Arthrose, nicht auch an den Fingern auftreten.
Könntest du sein? Ja, wiederholte Bewegung bei einem bestimmten,
bei dem es sind Arbeitbereite oder Sportlerinnen hat auch Arthrose mit wiederholten Desinformations, aber der Patientarbeitsartist,
der Prokofraum, ja, könnte sein, natürlich mit Tastotua schreibt sie.
Okay, okay, sie denken aber, es ist Pollenmaterie der Arthritis. Ja, eigentlich hat keine Steifigkeit.
Ja, eigentlich nicht genau. Hat die Patientin mir gesagt, da haben sie gefragt, wie lange ist an der Ort?
Wie bitte? Haben sie gefragt, wie lange die Steifigkeit an der Ort, morgen Steifigkeit?
Habe ich nicht gefragt, aber der Patient hat gesagt, wegen der dem oder geschwollenen Gelenke hat eine, diese Steifigkeit.
Deswegen habe ich nicht weiter gefragt.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, hat der Patient eine Morgensteifigkeit oder keine Morgensteifigkeit?
Hat eine Morgensteifigkeit.
Okay, da muss man mal fragen, wie lange das dauert und wichtig ist, ob es danach besser wird, ob sie Andauschmerzen hat.
Okay, und haben sie gefragt, welche Gelenke betroffen sind?
Grund- und Mittelgelenke hat gesagt und hat berichtet und so.
Okay, was machen Sie mit den Patienten, was Diagnostik machen Sie?
Ja, es würde ich die Patientin-Körperle-Untersuchung mit einer Pallpassion, Perkussion und ich sehe den Gelenke, ob geschwollene Gerüte, ob eine Hautveränderung hat oder
und ich taste diese Gelenke genau und verspüre mich dann auch,
dass es dabei eine Lupus-Erreterung wegen der Verdachauf-Lupus-Erreter-Motor-Sitz kann auch eine Hautveränderung und ja,
einen Schmetterling, Leck, vielleicht gibt es.
Was würde das bedeuten, wenn es einen Schmetterlings-Leck gibt, was bedeutet das?
Ja, es könnte eine Krankheit, so genannte Lupus-Erreter-Motor-Sitz, einen Zeitraum von dieser Erkrankung.
Deswegen könnte man vielleicht überprüfen oder inspirieren dafür und auch, ja, ich würde auch Labo-Untersuchungen durchführen mit Einzündungsparameter,
ja, als erstes Brutbild, ja, großes Bild kann man auch anfordern und auch Einzündungsparameter,
ja, PBSG und ja, Prokasten auch ein Säbtischartretes könnte es sein, aber so lange hier dauert und ...
Können Sie nochmal wiederholen? Ich habe das nicht ganz verstanden.
Welche wichtigen Werte müssten Sie bei dieser Prozellinat nehmen?
Ja, erste Brutbild haben Sie gesagt, natürlich und Einzündungsparameter, ja, PBSG, ja, PIS und ja, Prokastenin auch wegen der Säbtischartretes oder ja, könnte es sein,
also hier eine lange dauerte Einzündungsparameter und ja, noch eine CCP Antico, ja, CCP genau, CCP und Rheumafaktor kann man noch hier ...
Das ist schon gut, ja, das sieht schon aus. Natürlich Leberwert, Nierenwerte machen wir natürlich mit, ne?
Und ja, Antikörper und diese Antikörper auch vielleicht, ja und ja ...
Was machen Sie noch vor Diagnostik?
Ja, kann man auch Warteschal der Gelenke machen lassen oder ...
Was, einfacher?
Einfacher, ja.
Ob die, ja, diese Geschuvolen-Gelenke hat eine seröse oder vielleicht eine seröse Flüssigkeit hat oder eine Einzündliche, ja, ich meine eine Bakterielle, ja, das ist auch möglich.
Soll man eine Röntge mitmachen?
Ja, natürlich, bei der Einfache, ja, Röntgenaufnahme auch anfertigen, damit die ja Knöherne lesionen oder ja, mehr Knöherne ja,
einen Apparaten, ob richtig ...
Warum sind hier ...
Ich habe noch eine Frage, warum ist hier eine Atrose unwahrscheinlich?
Wahrscheinlich kann man nicht sagen, ja.
Auch kann man sagen?
Kann man sagen, weil ja, nachdem Sie ...
Wo hat die Patientin ihre Beschwerden?
Weil ich muss mal gelaufen.
Ja, beide Finger, beidseitig.
Beide Finger, alle Finger? Ja, alle Finger, alle Finger.
Wo gesagt du?
Okay, aber in welchen Bereichen der Finger hat sie die Schmerzen?
Hat sie ihnen den Daumen?
Grund- und Mittelgelenks?
Genau, ganz genau.
Und bei der Atrose, die die Schmerzen haben,
genau, und bei der Atrose ist es meistens ...
Die Stahlgelenke.
Genau, genau, genau.
Das ist ein richtiger Unterschied.
Bei Atroten ist die Et-Gelenke befallen,
bei Atritis, also Rheumaturge, die Atrübe sind meistens die
Grund- und Mittelgelenke befallen.
Ja.
Was würden Sie denn dieser Patientin,
die die Therapie haben?
Wissen Sie das?
Ja, beide Therapie würde ich als ...
Ja, nach der Bestätigung der Diagnose als Rheuma,
kann ich eine ...
eine Glucocorticoide mit ...
ja, Dexometer-Korticoid-Gabe
mit Dexometer-Zone oder Cortison
oder ja, eine ...
wie eine De-Mars oder ...
Ja, genau, sehr gut.
Sehr ... für dich eine Metatrexate oder ...
ja, ja.
... Goldschul-Gabe.
Diese Gold-Nicht-Gabe, das ist ...
Goldstandard.
Goldstandard, ja, Goldstandard, aber ...
ich habe diese Medikamente genau nicht erinnert.
Ich ...
aber ...
Und Cortison wäre eine Dauermedikation
oder nur vorübergehen?
Bei ...
bei Schupfphase oder ja,
Akkutmedikation kann man ...
auch Glucocorticoide geben,
aber es könnte sein auch eine Dauermedikation
zu nutzen.
Okay, aber Sie haben das jetzt richtig gesagt,
man würde Metatrexate, also MTX, geben, zum Beispiel.
Das kann man hoch dosieren
und man kann an Symptomkontrolle,
natürlich NSAR, also Evo-Prophen, Diplofenac,
sowas in der Art geben.
Ja, aber meine Zweifel ist hier,
nach der Evo-Prophen, hat der Patient nicht ...
Hat der ...
Er hat eine Nähfältige dosieren, 400 Milligramm.
Man kann erhöhen aus 600, 800,
man kann anderes NSA-Eier nehmen,
Diplofenac kann man nehmen, zum Beispiel.
Oha.
Er hat eine niedrige Dosierung gehabt.
Sie, Fader, Sie.
Sie, ja.
Richtig.
Die Verfügung ist zeitlos.
Die Verfügung ist fertig, okay.
Gut.
Noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ganz richtig.
Patienten muss aufhören zu rauchen, ne?
Ja.
Aber für Stück, ja, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, aber schon seit 30 Jahren, ne?
Ja, da seit 30 Jahren.
Aufhören zu rauchen, ne?
Und auch gutes Physiotherapie kann man machen,
ein bisschen, ne?
Ja, richtig.
So eine Therapie, so was in der Art,
kann man machen, ne?
Okay, ja, Entschuldigung,
diese Fahr-
ist für mich ein bisschen verrennt.
Wie meine Land,
ja, nicht so häufig vorkommt,
oder...